bonjour allez-vous bien moi ça va
écouter aujourd'hui je fais cette vidéo
totalement à l'improviste pas ce qu'il
s'est passé un truc qui n'était pas
prévu hier j'ai tourné deux vidéos donc
l'une sur un jeu où c'était une fête
foraine et en fait je me suis pas amusé
à la tournée c'est le genre de jeu sur
lequel j'aurai fait des vidéos avant et
il se trouve qu'en fait ça m'amuse plus
en fait j'ai tourné je me suis
moyennement amusé et en fait au montage
ces désastres 8 tu peux rien en tirer
les gens vont vraiment pas rire et
passer un bon moment devant la vidéo
parce que j'ai moi même pas passer un
bon moment quand je joue à ce jeu est en
fait c'est la première fois en six ans
que ça m'arrive c'est à dire faire ce
que je faisais tous les jours pendant
très longtemps mais d'un coup ça m'amuse
plus est en fait j'ai trouvé pourquoi
j'avais j'avais ce problème c'est que
dernièrement j'ai fait des vidéos dans
lesquelles je me suis des mêmes des
projets dans lesquels je me suis éclatée
comme jamais et le clip avec maxence il
ya eu la vidéo avec big flo et oli ya eu
la vidéo avec marc saikali thoen à tous
et son et vidéo vous avez
particulièrement aimé et ce sont des
vidéos que j'ai particulièrement aimé
faire moi aussi donc en fait il ya
vraiment un lien entre les vidéos entre
le plaisir que je prends surtout en âge
et le plaisir que vous avez en la
regardant c'est totalement
proportionnelle plus que jamais et ses
deux meilleures semaines voulons montrer
j'ai juste envie de faire ce que j'aime
sur youtube et sur un an ce pas ce que
j'ai fait en fait je me suis rappelé
pourquoi j'avais commencé youtube
c'était pour faire des vidéos à l'époque
c'est avec mes potes du lycée
en fait c'était pour délirer à plusieurs
j'ai commencé les vidéos pour délirer à
plusieurs pour m'amuser à plusieurs et
puis au bout d'un moment je me suis très
vite rendu compte qu'à l'époque pour
marcher sur youtube il fallait faire du
contenu fréquemment il fallait en sorte
sortir des vidéos souvent peu importe
les vidéos il fallait en sortir donc
fait entrer dans ce truc là de faire
plusieurs vidéos par semaine parce qu'il
fallait faire ça pour pour que ta chaîne
soit mise en avant que tes vidéos soient
mises en avant et ont cherché tous à
être mis en avant sans dire que ça en
faisant des bonnes vidéos construit mis
en avant est pas en faisant x nombre de
vidéos par semaine pour le plus clair
possible en gros quand tu t'imposes un
rythme de 4 vidéos par semaine
tu vas faire deux vidéos qui qui vont
vraiment plaire que tu vas apprécié et
tu vas faire une ou deux vidéos que je
dirais de transition c'est à dire tu
sais que c'est pas ouf
mais tu le fais quand même parce que tu
tiens à mettre tes quatre vidéos en
ligne par semaine et à faire plus
de vue que les autres et ce système là
j'en ai marre je veux plus procéder
comme ça je veux être fier de chaque
[ __ ] de vidéos que je mets en ligne
sur ma chaîne sans penser au stade sans
penser aux abonnés juste faire du
contenu que j'aime faire que j'aime
présenter aux gens et du coup c'est
forcément un peu plus de vidéo à
plusieurs parce que je trouve que tu
partages plus de choses dans les vidéos
à plusieurs que dans les vidéos sol et
dans les vidéos sol c'est un peu plus de
trucs originaux ou alors des trucs sur
des jeux comme actuellement mais quand
tu aimes vraiment le jeu pas quand tu te
dis ah ouais ça c'est un peu drôle à lui
on va faire ça de façon fonctionnelle
vidéo du jour aller ça je veux plus
procéder de cette manière là c'est de
cette manière là que je marche depuis
six ans et en m'imposant quatre vidéos
par semaine quitte à ce qu'ils aient des
vidéos qu'ils soient pas au fait je sais
qu'elles sont pas au fait au tournage je
me force à faire semblant d'aimer ce que
je suis en train de faire alors que
j'aime pas plus que ça et je trouve ça
nul à la longue de faire ça et je pense
que avec le chemin que j'ai parcouru
aujourd'hui je peux faire que ce que
j'aime et m'éviter ces espèces de vidéos
de transition ça veut pas dire plus de
jeux vidéo attention c'est pas ce que je
dis mais ça veut dire plus de vidéos où
je fais semblant
j'espère que c'est clair je sais pas si
c'est clair j'ai pu mieux possible
je pense que c'est un peu compréhensible
je me tâte la barbichette quand je pars
en vacances et la semaine prochaine je
pars une semaine au canada avec clément
on va faire des vidéos là bas je vais
prolonger mon voyage d'une semaine je la
bats pour avoir une vraie semaine de
vacances je fais pas de vidéo comme je
pars habituellement en vacances je la
semaine d'avant je prépare huit vidéos
au lieu de 4 je dois retourner huit en
cinq jours et en fait c'est totalement
impossible de trouver en quatre cinq
jours
8 idée de vidéos bien et surtout de
pouvoir le faire ce n'est techniquement
pas possible
et là je suis dans cette situation où
j'avais mon programme la semaine
prochaine je pars au canada et peut-être
que du coup il y aura qu une vidéo qui
sera mise en ligne peut-être les quatre
que je voulais mettre en ligne si j'y
arrive si j'ai les idées et si ça me
plaît mais si j'ai pas les idées et ben
je veux pas faire de truc nul histoire
d'avoir quelle vidéo à mettre en ligne
je veux que d'enjeux mettre une vidéo en
ligne gens soient fiers que moi même
j'ai pas honte
en la regardant parce qu'il ya des
vidéos ou quand je les regarde je quand
quelqu'un leur égard écoutez moi je suis
pas bien jeu et ça montre qu'il ya un
vrai problème avec ces vidéos là c'est
que je suis pas fier et je joue jusqu'à
en avoir à me sentir mal à l'aise quand
quelqu'un à regarder à côté de moi c'est
grave quand même en m'imposant ce [ __ ]
de rides de cadeaux par semaine je
n'arrive pas à être fière de tout ce que
je sors et ça me ça me plaît pas du tout
peut-être que je suis moins en moins
indulgent avec moi même et c'est normal
à partir d'aujourd'hui je mettrais
peut-être plus quatre vidéos en ligne
par semaine je ferai peut-être moins de
vue le cadre est peut-être moins
d'abonnés mais je serai fier de ce que
je ferai voilà
ça fait du bien les vieux vont forcément
baisser si chez moins deux vidéos et
quant à youtube heures psychologiquement
voir s'est vu baisser je trouve que
c'est dur tu dis merde [ __ ] j'ai
toujours fait moi je sais pas je fais 90
millions de vues par mois balle à
jeffrey soixante ou soixante dix j'en
sais rien ou 40 ans c'est rien mais
[ __ ] au moins je serai hyper bien dans
mes baskets
c'est ce que je veux dans ma vie en fait
cet hyper bien dans mes baskets quitte à
faire moins de vue c'est pas grave mais
à faire du contenu dont je suis fier
jeter de bonne humeur en me levant je
traite bonne humeur en levant et
j'aimerais encore plus ma vie et c'est
ça que je veux aujourd'hui donc soyez
pas surpris dans les semaines à venir ça
m'a fait du bien de vous parler de ça
c'est pas facile j'espère que vous serez
pas déçu que mon voudrais pas ou quoi
ça va p'tet d'en décevoir certains mais
franchement c'est pour mon bien et ceci
pour votre bien pour que chaque vidéo
soit vraiment cool ça veut pas dire que
rak une ou des vidéos par semaine pas du
tout il y aura peut-être des x 4 vidéos
comme actuellement et si on n'a que deux
bas ce sera 2 - qu'habituellement mais
moi ce sera deux vidéos pareil dont je
serai fier qu'ils sont vraiment cool
c'est un gros changement pour moi
psychologiquement et c'est positif je
sais pas si vous pouvez vous rendre
compte mais voilà être fier de ce que tu
mets en ligne ne pas avoir trop de
pression être prêt à voir tes stade bc
mettant bat les couilles parce que ce
que tu veux c'est continuer à qui fait
ton métier continue à faire kiffer les
gens et continuer à faire kiffer toi
même
les vidéos dans son coeur meilleurs et
même si les stats ne sont que moins bon
je m'en fous je veux faire ce que j'aime
et j'ai la chance de pouvoir faire ce
que j'aime
donc autant procéder comme ça et pas
autrement et voilà bientôt une prochaine
vidéo reposez vous bien pendant les
vacances ou courage pour le taf y en a
qui t'a fait puis stark la prochaine
vous vous plaire vous en faites pas
j'aurai de l'énergie c'est juste
qu'aujourd'hui se prendre la réalité en
face et s'apercevoir que on n'est plus
comme avant quelque on a envie de
nouvelles choses et prendre le courage
de changer sa manière de faire quitte à
ce que ça déplaise aux gens que tu as
qu'on marche moins bien c'est pas facile
mais c'était important que le fasse
c'est fait à bientôt et puis j'espère
que cette vidéo vous plairont au revoir